so peter we just played the new dragon
ball game this is the first dragon ball
z game for current gen but i mean is
there anything even new about it
i know you're saying like a lot of
dragon ball z games are pretty similar
they always promise like you can relive
the scenes from the game and they're
from the show and
yeah like that's true uh and this game
has all those elements as well but
there's a uh a sort of a story behind it
all so someone is messing with the
history of the dragon ball z universe
and trunks the character who's famous
for like time traveling in that series
uh he summons he gets the seven dragon
balls summons shenlong the dragon and
then calls you to help him go back and
fix all these problems that have
happened it's pretty important right you
messed up past the future hit screw
so yeah i mean you get to create your
own character you customize it using
various acts but you know
the height the weight the clothing the
hair you want and you look like your own
original dragon ball z character and you
kind of just go back in time and
and help fix all the problems of the
past i heard there's also online aspects
to this game a little bit so with your
customizable character you can go to
this place that we just called tokitoki
and that is this little city where the
uh
you can say the kai or the gods of time
live and you're there with other people
and it's sort of like an online lobby
and from there you can like you know
fight against them or uh there are some
co-op elements as well but really it's
just about using your own character that
you create and leveling him up and
customizing you know his or her look and
then just sort of
being an integral part of the story in a
way that was in the past like
pre-destined but now it's sort of like
in your control this is new it's kind of
interesting